wir schauen dann mal ins Ausland da ist
man nämlich deutlich kreativer es gibt
ein bisschen was zu lernen für die
haarbacks Lindner scholzens und so
weiter schauen Sie
Action nein das ist nicht der Trailer
des neuen James Bond films und nein das
ist auch nicht Daniel Craig sondern Joel
rasmusoff Tourismusminister Israels
seine Ähnlichkeit mit Bond Darsteller
Craig ist verblüffend in wahrer 007
Manier spielt rasrosoft die epischsten
Szene nach ob Martini trinken dann der
Bar oder beim Surfen auf hoher See er
lebt den Boss Style dabei geht der
Minister jedoch nicht auf Gangster
sondern auf urlauberjagd sein Ziel den
Tourismus für sein Land ankurbeln und
damit das auch wirklich gelingt hat er
natürlich auch das 007 Motto adaptiert
der Name ist Israel Staat Israel
Politiker Armen Filmrollen nach das kann
ein klarer Imagegewinn sein ja wow
Respekt da an den israelischen
Tourismusminister also das bringt auf
jeden Fall international Aufmerksamkeit
und ist sicherlich für die Wahrnehmung
des Landes erstmal eine gute Sache und
ich persönlich finde das toll wenn ein
Politiker wie sagt man immer so schön
mal den Hintern in der Hose hat auch mal
was nicht polit so ein typisches zu
machen Politiker in Filmrollen können
das auch wir Deutschen nun ja Markus
Söder hat es zumindest mal versucht der
bayerische Ministerpräsident
präsentierte sich beim Fasching in
Franken als Kultfigur Schreck kein
Vergleich zum israelischen Bond Grün von
Neid wird man da eher nicht ja das ist
ja wie immer es zahlt ja alles auf einen
Markenbild eines Politikers ein und das
ist natürlich Bilder die mit den
Menschen assoziiert werden das sind ja
immer Dinge die dann im politischen
Diskurs auch wieder gegen einen
verwendet werden und man sagt das lenkt
dann aber auch wieder von der Politik ab
und das möchte man ja eigentlich auch
nicht aber wie macht man es dann nun
richtig wir haben da ein paar Vorschläge
wie wäre es zum Beispiel mit
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach als
Meister Yoda aus Star Wars mit mask wars
der Krieg der Sterne zum Krieg gegen
Corona passen dafür hat Meister Karl wie
immer einen weißen Rat Maske tragen du
sollst bleiben wir in der SPD auch
Verteidigungsministerin Christine
Lambrecht hat durchaus Grund der Image
aufzupolieren gelingen kann das durch
die neue Hauptrolle in Top Gun oder
vielmehr top bunt wenn sie als
weiblicher Maverick auch nur halb so
viele junge Männer zur Armee bringt wie
das Original dann sind die
Nachwuchssorgen der Bundeswehr für immer
erledigt apropos Nachwuchs auch an die
jungen Filmfans haben wir gedacht sie
kriegen von den Minions nicht genug wie
wäre es mit märz in der Hauptrolle
natürlich CDU-Chef Friedrich Merz als
Meister grub und das Sidekick dürfen
natürlich die gelben Minions nicht
fehlen hier in der Hauptrolle FDP-Chef
Christian Lindner gelb-schwarze liebe
einfach legendär einen Image Booster
kann auch er gebrauchen Robert Habeck
der uns in der Energiekrise zum Strom
und Gas sparen bringen möchte und vor
dem Blackout warnt eine Aufgabe für
knallharte Kerle daher heizt langsam der
Bruce Willis der Grünen nur echt mit dem
Thermostat in der Hand allerdings
positives Image ist das eine aber zum
Schluss muss Werbung auch gefallen und
da kann Joel Rasmus auf so schnell
niemand das Wasser reichen
tja wenn man auch so eine Kampagne kommt
unsere chefreporterin Antonia Jamin die
hat jetzt exklusiv mit dem
007 Minister darüber gesprochen
guten Tag Herr Minister raus oder soll
ich sie besser Mister nennen
sie können mich ruhig Mister Rosas auf
nennen aber in den letzten Tagen bin ich
wirklich zu Mister Bond geworden also
später angefangen wann hat man ihnen das
erste mal gesagt dass sie aussehen wie
Daniel Craig
das geht schon länger so das erste mal
an dass ich mich noch erinnere ist Jahre
her ich war am Flughafen und stand beim
Security Check und da hat jemand gerufen
hey da ist doch Daniel Craig und sofort
wollten alle mit mir Fotos machen das
war schon komisch und ich musste sofort
lachen und seitdem passiert mir das fast
täglich dass irgendwer kommt und sagt
sag mal weißt du eigentlich wem du
ähnlich siehst und dann sage ich immer
ja ja ich weiß schon Mister Bond meinst
du bestimmt
[Musik]
wenn sie draußen einfach rumlaufen dass
Leute auf sie zugehen und behaupten sie
wären Daniel Craig
ja das passiert mir wirklich sehr oft
von wo kam eigentlich die Idee wir haben
den Film gerade schon gezeigt der
israelische Tourismusminister als James
Bond
Thomas
das hat damit angefangen dass mich
einmal Paparazzi am Strand fotografiert
haben mich gerade aus dem Wasser kam und
die wollten mich dann auch sofort
interviewen und dann haben wir so ein
bisschen rumgescherzt und da entstand
dann die Idee dass man meine Ähnlichkeit
mit 007 doch auch irgendwie fürs
Marketing nutzen könnte in der
Tourismusbranche und jetzt sind wir halt
in der Nebensaison in Israel und alle
meinten wir sollten mehr Werbung machen
für unser schönes Land und da dachte ich
mir das wäre doch mal was schließlich
feiert James Bond jetzt auch 60-jähriges
Jubiläum und da dachten wir das passt
jetzt machen wir mal was das viral geht
und ja es funktioniert der Clip wird
millionenfach angeklickt und geht um die
Welt und ich hoffe dass das jetzt auch
bewirkt dass die Leute Lust bekommen mal
in unser schönes Land zu reisen
inwiefern ist dieser Clip auch Teil der
Wahlkampagne die fünfte Parlamentswahl
findet ja in wenigen Tagen schon statt
also mit der Wahl hat das weniger zu tun
wie schon erwähnt wir haben gerade
Nebensaison und da hilft so ein bisschen
Werbung einfach immer und der
Premierminister ja der begrüßt das
natürlich auch wenn wir für unsere
branchewerbung machen
Wahlkampf ist ja außerdem irgendwie
immer es ist eher so dass ich als
Minister in der Tourismusbranche mein
bestes geben will und wenn das jetzt
dabei hilft die Branche anzukurbeln dann
ist das doch super
lieber Herr Minister oder James Bond
vielen Dank
ich danke Ihnen
ein Minister der sagt er wird ständig
mit Daniel Craig mit James Bond
verwechselt es gibt nicht so viele
Minister Deutschland den das ständig
passiert
[Musik]